[rock music playing]
MIKE: Is that it?
It certainly looks like it.
[cheering]
Oh, my goodness gracious.
Yeah, man.
We found Aeromith's van.
It's history, baby.
Raymond's boots on the ground.
He's animated.
He's excited.
This is cool.
I'm afraid to
say how long it is,
but it's like 40 years has
we've been in this thing.
I just flashed
back to when we first
started the band because
it was an amazing thing.
All of a sudden, here's
the thing that we lived in.
It was like our dressing room.
It was like a rolling hotel.
I'll tell you right now, I
have a picture of the inside
of this van with me in it.
- Really?
- Get out of here.
- Yes I do.
Yes I do.
- Do you really?
I have a picture of
me inside this van.
It was-- it-- it was in
the "Draw The Line" book.
There's a picture of me and
Steven Tyler, and Joey Kramer,
and Joe Perry inside--
MIKE: Yeah, from the back door.
Inside the van
from the back door.
FRANK: But in the windows--
That's cool.
MIKE: Which one are you?
RAYMOND: That's me
with the long hair.
MIKE: Oh, that's
you right there.
RAY: Yeah, that's me all right.
[laughing]
Back when my hair was brown.
RAYMOND: We put the band
together originally in 1970.
I was around until
about almost 1972.
And then I left the band,
and I moved up to Maine.
I wanted to be a hippie.
And then about a year
later, Steven called me up.
He said, we just
signed our first album.
Dude, I want you to come
back to work for the band.
So I came back to work for
the band, not as a musician,
but as one of the guys
in that organization.
I decided, listen,
I have a good idea.
Why don't we start a
merchandise company.
I redesigned the Aerosmith logo
to the one that we use today,
and I went into the
merchandise business with them.
And that's what I did
for about eight years.
So I was with them
altogether until about 1979.
Yeah.
Look, look, look,
look, look, the rug.
That's the rug.
Look, it's the rug.
This is it, baby.
Cool.
Get out of here.
This is it.
This is the Aerosmith
van from 1970.
MIKE: Raymond is so
excited and so jacked up,
that he's like,
dude, take a picture
of me in this same spot.
Get the rug in.
There it is, right there, man.
RAYMOND: All right, man.
I mean, you couldn't even
write this kind of stuff.
It's taken me back, because
I remember the van just the way
it is like this.
There was like six of us.
There are five guys in
the band and Mark Lehman,
who owned the van.
And we would play jobs
up in New Hampshire.
We'd drive from Boston up
to New Hampshire for $125,
that after a gas, and
the tolls, and the food,
and back, we'd all make
like about $3 a piece.
And it just reminded me
of the humble beginnings,
and I look at where
they've gone today.
It's just amazing.
- Look at the paint.
So who painted this?
RAYMOND: Mark Lehman, who was
the guy who owned the van,
had a friend in Boston,
that was like an artist.
So he decided to do it all
chrome version of himself.
And he came up.
FRANK: That's like the keep
on trucking dude or something.
Oh, that's him.
That's Mark.
FRANK: It's him?
MIKE: That's the guy that drove?
RAYMOND: That's
what he looked like.
Yeah.
MIKE: Oh, that's
what he looked like?
RAYMOND: That's what
he looked like exactly.
MIKE: Yeah.
- No, no, no.
In the song, in the song which
says, "bald as an egg at 18,"
that's what he's talking about.
Oh, he was 18 and bald?
RAYMOND: He's
talking about that.
FRANK: Yeah.
RAYMOND: That's who
he's talking about.
MIKE: Oh, my gosh.
FRANK: Wow.
After I left the band, I
heard a story that they had
a foreign [inaudible]
Mark, and he just
disappeared into nowhere, man.
Raymond's like, Mark took off.
We had no idea where he
was, and when he took off,
he took the van.
He owned it.
And now, I guess this is where
it's been all these years.
The whole thing
just disappeared.
Joe and Mark were good friends
before we formed the band.
This is definitely the van.
There's no doubt about it.
This is it.
MIKE: Congratulations, man.
RAYMOND: You found it, man.
FRANK: This is pretty cool.
MIKE: That's all you
need to hear, man.
FRANK: Yeah.
A real important
thing here is that that
is the first time that
Aerosmith was ever written out.
Now, we never wound
up using a logo.
I myself designed the
logo that we use today,
but that's the first time
it was ever written out.
FRANK: Phil's getting
awful quiet over there.
I can see his eyes getting big.
The wheels are spinning.
It's hitting him.
How did you guys
come up with the name?
Well, Joey Kramer, apparently
when he was in high school,
used to scribble
names for bands.
And that's one of the
names that he came up with.
MIKE: Aerosmith, huh?
RAYMOND: Yeah.
So he had a vision
of being in a band.
Oh, yeah.
Yeah, definitely.
He was spending his time in
class writing names of bands
down.
Exactly, exactly, yeah.
He was destined
to be a musician.
Exactly.
It was meant to be.
When Raymond actually
confirmed the fact
that it was the real thing,
the excitement in him
got me excited.
MIKE: I very much
appreciate you coming out
here on such a short notice.
- Yeah.
I'm back in 1970
again, and I felt
like, you know what, I had a
lot of good times in this van.
And I'm glad that we found it.